[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález en perú el
presidente de ese país pedro castillo
enfrentará a la que sería su segunda
moción de juicio político desde que
asumió el cargo de presidente el pasado
28 de julio en la misma jornada algunos
de los nuevos integrantes de su gabinete
también enfrentarán un voto de confianza
por parte del congreso la moción es
impulsada por jorge montoya un
congresista del partido renovación
popular que comenzó la recolección de
firmas necesarias para llevar esta
moción al congreso ya fue a recibir allí
esto a raíz de las presuntas
revelaciones de la empresaria karelin
lópez quien afirmó que el presidente
castillo estaría involucrado en actos de
corrupción para que la moción llegue a
una primera instancia es decir para su
presentación ante el congreso son
necesarias las firmas de 26 legisladores
y 52 votos para iniciar un debate en el
marco de un juicio político
posteriormente si 87 de los 130
integrantes del congreso de la república
de perú vota y respaldan la moción del
presidente castillo sería destituido que
es un posible escenario hasta el momento
cuatro partidos de la oposición con 53
escaños en el legislativo han dicho que
están respaldando esta moción también en
la jornada como les decía la atención en
perú está concentrada en esa
presentación del pleno del gabinete
encabezada por aníbal torres que es el
presidente del consejo de ministros de
perú para solicitar el voto de confianza
por parte del parlamento se trata del
cuarto gabinete en siete meses de
gobierno y el tercero en pedir la
confianza del parlamento hoy en el
debate de france 24 damos una mirada a
cómo está la situación política en perú
en esa nación suramericana y para
analizar este tema hemos invitado en la
capital peruana la ciudad de lima a
alexandra a meses de es politóloga
también se une esta conversación desde
la ciudad de lima luciano lópez él es
analista político constitucionalista y
profesor de las facultades de derecho de
las escuelas de posgrado de la
universidad católica de perú
ustedes también nuestros televidentes
pueden participar en este debate con
todos sus comentarios y sus preguntas
las pueden hacer a través de nuestras
redes sociales no se encuentran en
facebook en instagram en twitter estamos
como france24 guión bajo es santi logo
que es mi cuenta personal les recuerdo
la etiqueta numeral el debate efe 24
esperamos todos los comentarios ya
tenemos algo de contexto tenemos a los
invitados quiero darle la palabra
entonces alexandra en la ciudad de lima
para comenzar este debate y lo que llama
la atención a alexandra es que en perú
nuevamente se enfrenta a una posible
moción de vacancia el presidente
nuevamente estaría entonces acercándose
a las puertas de una nueva crisis
política como lo vio usted
si efectivamente estamos nuevamente en
una situación de crisis pareciera que ya
los términos de vacancia o inclusive
cierre del congreso son prácticas ya
institucionalizadas como un juicio
político o una sanción política ante los
diversos poderes del estado y por lo
tanto pues creo que dadas las
condiciones que tenemos hoy el escenario
más posible es la vacancia no creo
particularmente que la vacancia se pueda
dar próximamente en un futuro muy
cercano pero que considero según el
análisis cómo está la situación de que
esa es la salida más posible en este año
luciano también allí en la ciudad de
lima la capital de perú su opinión pero
nuevamente
próximo a empezar una nueva crisis
política a una posible vacancia en una
posible moción de vacancia para el
presidente ya fue instaurada allí en el
congreso y ya comienza su trámite
interno
si indudablemente todo buenas tardes
a través de las cámaras de france 24 a
lanzar una felicitación por el día de la
mujer tanto alexandra a ambos como a
todas las mujeres de latinoamérica
sobre el tema en concreto
definitivamente he coincidido con la
vivencia alexandra estamos en una crisis
política en realidad arrastrada
agudizada por la ineficiencia del
gobierno del señor castillo
profundizada además por los casos de
corrupción que dan de alguna manera y
ahí está a esta actuación del parlamento
que tampoco goza de aceptación popular
eso creo que también es muy importante
señalarlo está en niveles incluso hasta
más bajo que el propio presidente
castillo la sensación que se es que se
tiene aquí en el perú y que por eso a
través sobre todo en las redes sociales
que hoy mueven mucho la comunicación y
los mensajes en el espacio político es
que se vayan todos no entonces
un posible ese enlace es siempre y
cuando lleguen a tener los votos
aparentemente no los tienen tienen como
para como ustedes mismos lo han
anunciado presentar esta moción para que
se pueda dar el trámite
quizá en el momento de admitir la y
admitir la significa que se abre ese
procedimiento que además se ve aquí en
el perú les comento es muy es un
procedimiento muy corto en una semana
pueden sacar un presidente pero tendrán
los 87 votos es un pronóstico reservado
indudablemente luciano continuó con
usted para hacer la ronda a la inversa y
le pregunto ya fue presentado esto ante
el congreso que trámite interno tiene
esto ya usted nos avanza que estoy en
contados días tal vez en una semana
puede dar un resultado
como es el trámite interno de este tipo
de requerimientos
grosso modo como ustedes lo presentaron
al inicio en el contexto ya tiene el
mínimo de firmas para presentar la
moción así que una vez presentada ante
el congreso de la república la
presidenta de este poder del estado
tiene que dar cuenta la representación
nacional y luego se votas su admisión
la admisión significa darle trámite y
por tanto citar al presidente de la
república y a su abogado para que hagan
su derecho de defensa para ello
necesitan 52 votos el hecho de que hayan
recogido ese número es también una
muestra de parte de las fuerzas
políticas de decirle al presidente
tenemos el poder y sobre todo los votos
para que vengas aquí el parlamento y a
dar explicaciones y por lo cual habría
han desnaturalizado también el trámite
esa vacancia pero en todo caso en los
hechos es lo que va a ocurrir hasta ahí
creo que van a poder quedar porque ha
coincidido con alexandra si tendrán los
87 votos para que en una semana que se
siente en trámite tan rápido luego del
debate y de escuchar al castillo y a su
abogado tengan la fuerza como para
bajarlo depende de que otras evidencias
puedan en el camino en la verdad porque
lo que ha abierto carril y lópez en
realidad es una caja de pandora se
inspiran muchas cosas en realidad
alexandra usted no mencionaba los bajos
índices de popularidad del presidente
castillo también ese descontento
generalizado entre diferentes sectores
de la sociedad peruana que esta maniobra
que tanto tiene de componente político
de tratar de sacarse a castillo del
camino o que de verdad hay una necesidad
de una vacancia del presidente por estas
acusaciones de corrupción que están en
curso que ya vamos a analizar más
adelante y que a lo largo de estos siete
meses el presidente no ha logrado ni
conformar un gabinete ni ha logrado
estabilizar al país cuál es su análisis
bueno es una combinación de las dos
cosas que mencionas yo no había visto en
los últimos 20 años digamos de
democracia plena que hemos tenido en
donde se cuestione la veracidad de los
resultados de un proceso electoral
entonces pedro castillo es una figura
presidencial es un actor político que
llegó a la presidencia con muchas dudas
por parte de la ciudadanía con mucha
desconfianza por parte de la ciudadanía
simplemente porque no reconocía a este
actor como el futuro presidente de la
república entonces durante la primera
semana de gobierno pedro castillo ya se
estaba hablando de la posibilidad de
bajarlo esto hizo sin embargo que la
ciudadanía reaccione de manera adversa
al congreso y es por esto que pese a que
hoy pedro castillo tiene una gran
desaprobación porque no está
convirtiendo esta narrativa de no más no
más pobres en un país rico no la está
convirtiendo en políticas públicas
reales a favor de la ciudadanía a favor
de los más vulnerables porque no se está
viendo digamos acciones sino lo que se
está viendo es corrupción
empieza esta esta desconfianza dejo te
hace esta baja de popularidad pero por
otro lado tenemos un congreso también
bastante desgastado con una alta también
desaprobación de hecho la presidenta del
congreso hoy tiene un poquito más de
desaprobación que pedro castillo
entonces
tampoco es que la ciudadanía esté
apoyando a el congreso por lo tanto esta
arenga este hashtag que menciono luciano
que se vayan todos termina siendo la
opción más popular para la gente estamos
hablando que esta sería la segunda
moción de vacancia del presidente
castillo en diciembre tuvo que hacer
frente a la primera de ellas digamos que
en diciembre se salvó logró obtener los
votos necesarios para permanecer en el
cargo alexandra que diferencia esta
moción de diciembre y las cargas que
había a nivel de las fuerzas políticas
en el parlamento peruano y lo que vemos
dos meses después en el 2022 con esta
segunda moción
pasan varias cosas el principal factor
es el tiempo en diciembre el año pasado
todavía se tenía unos primeros seis
meses en una especie de tregua en donde
la ciudadanía le estaba dando el
beneficio de la duda pero este plazo se
dio en un lapso en donde también fueron
destapándose ciertos actos de corrupción
como el de care link lópez en donde se
fue conociendo esta situación y empezó a
generar mucho rechazo y desconfianza
ahora lo que tenemos es en un momento
preciso para empezar a calentar la
situación de la vacancia en el
parlamento sumado a un desmantelamiento
que está ocurriendo dentro del aparato
burocrático no sólo se trata de destapes
de corrupción sino que las personas que
se están colocando en los puestos más
claves del estado enfrente justamente a
un servicio civil de débil digamos en
donde no tenemos una carrera pública
sólida estos estos puestos están siendo
ocupados por personas que no solo están
calificadas para el cargo sino que
tienen serias denuncias de corrupción
serias denuncias de violencia contra la
mujer y que genera mucho rechazo a la
ciudadanía entonces se va calentando
esta situación pero como digo creo que
todavía no llegan a los votos
suficientes como para que la vacancia se
pueda dar pronto bueno no llegan a los
votos suficientes es la opinión de
alexandra de luciano también planteaba
algo similar quiero que profundizamos
justamente en ese tema como están
repartidas entonces las cargas allí en
perú para quienes no conocemos a
profundidad la política peruana que
partidos podrían entrar allí a apoyar
este pedido de vacancia por parte del
senador montoya como lo ve usted luciana
puedo definitivamente hoy por ejemplo un
destacado periodista de uno de los
medios importantes de este país que es
el diario el comercio señala en sus
redes sociales de que el conteo de los
votos hay dos bancadas o sea dos grupos
parlamentarios que podrían inclinar la
balanza
estamos hablando de alianza por el
progreso y estamos hablando de somos
perú tenemos nosotros un parlamento con
varias bancadas porque estaba bastante
fragmentado pero según las sumas y
restas aparentemente estos dos grupos
parlamentarios podrían inclinar la
balanza como mencionábamos hace hace un
momento
este este calentamiento de esta escena
política que a la cual se refería
alexandra que con la presentación esta
moción que tener 52 votos para poderlo
citar al castillo que esto podría
ocurrir en el lapso de una semana me da
la impresión que este pronóstico
reservado al que podría llegar se los 87
votos y que quizás estas dos bancadas
puedan inclinar la balanza a favor de la
vacancia creo que va a depender de la
evidencia que pueda estar saliendo en
los próximos días y dijo hago ese
pronóstico
por una razón muy sencilla lo que se ha
sujetado esta señora que se llama karen
lópez que es una de la torá pues es una
relación premiada un mecanismo que
existe en varias partes del mundo de
américa latina
lo que hace es que la fiscalía tenga que
corroborar y como estamos hablando de un
caso de notorio interés público esas
evidencias se van a aplicar a la prensa
no me sorprendería que justamente ésta
vacancia como en política nada es
casualidad se puede haber presentado en
estos momentos porque se tiene
proyectado que pueda salir alguna
evidencia de aller pública porque los
actos de corrupción que han venido
acompañando al señor castillo en los
últimos tiempos son bastante sonoros y
sobre todo esta aparición de karim lópez
me parece que es clave en este escenario
claves por eso sigo si se admite se
tramita lo llaman al castillo y sale una
evidencia
creo que eso podría generar que estas
bancadas que puedan que son las que van
a inclinar la balanza se animen y
entonces estemos frente a un desenlace
de esa naturaleza porque si fuera hoy
después de lo que dice también y también
coincido no tienen los votos creo que va
a depender de la evidencia que pueda
salir en los próximos días alexander con
un escenario como el que nos describe
luciano podríamos también ver y puede
ser una de las opciones una renuncia
anticipada del presidente podría ser el
caso
es el escenario menos viable desde mi
perspectiva menos posible desde mi
perspectiva porque dada la situación
precisamente de denuncias y estos
escapes que han salido a raíz de la
figura de la colaboración eficaz en la
que se va a asumir care link lópez pues
en este momento no le conviene al
presidente castillo pensar en una
renuncia porque de hecho tenemos a
nuestros ex presidentes vivos y
perseguidos por la justicia
presos entonces con juicios entonces no
es una situación que le convenga a pedro
castillo por lo que creo que la opción
por la que él más bien va a optar es por
resistir lo más que se pueda no sin
embargo un poco para complementar en lo
que sostiene enuncia no es que no
solamente tenemos varias bancadas de
manera atomizada en el gobierno sino que
tenemos a demás individuos tenemos 130
congresistas y por lo tanto yo me
atrevería a decir da esta atomización y
esta precariedad del sistema de partidos
políticos que prácticamente tenemos 130
bancadas digamos individuos que piensan
por sí solos digamos y por eso es que
dentro de estas propias denuncias que se
hace a través de karel y lópez se
menciona justamente a algunos
congresistas vinculados a actos de
corrupción con el ejecutivo que no son
de la bancada oficialista sino más bien
de la bancada la que pertenece hoy la
presidenta del congreso que representa a
la oposición entonces vamos a ver cómo
se juegan las cartas para esta próxima
moción de vacancia y definitivamente con
un buen destape que pueda suceder en
estos días puede ser digamos algo que
incline la balanza hacia la vacancia
pero todavía creo que el momento no se
ha calentado lo suficiente para ello
claro este capítulo en la historia de
perú en la historia de este gobierno
apenas está comenzando apenas están
repartiéndose las cartas en la mesa en
alexandra luciano el mismo presidente
castillo ha criticado a la fiscalía y en
perú ha dicho la fiscalía estaría
formando parte de un complot para
desestabilizar al gobierno peruano
luciano que tanta confianza hay en la
institucionalidad peruana en una entidad
como la fiscalía que tanto se puede
confiar y que tanta independencia de
poderes hay allí de cara a este
escenario político que se está empezando
a armar allí
bueno empiezo por lo último la
independencia es una independencia
formal y lo llamo formal porque en los
hechos lo que podemos decir es que hay
la actuación individual de ciertos
representantes del ministerio público
que son los que han llevado adelante los
destapes en los últimos tiempos y lo que
puede haber puesto contra las cuerdas y
además en prisión a varios este
expresidente eso o con órdenes de
captura de otros no
eso significa entonces que esas
iniciativas individuales es lo que
motiva que por ejemplo el abogado de
karelin lo elegido estratégicamente no
ir ante el fiscal contra la corrupción
porque está más bien bajo sospecha que
pueda estar en un tinglado más bien de
protección de algunos personajes ligados
de gobierno y hay escogido más bien
hacer la delación frente al equipo
especial de fiscales que vio y que ve el
caso famosísimo de la baja pto está
dirigido por un fiscal con muy buena
reputación que es el doctor rafael vela
entonces eso da una muestra de que en
realidad tenemos una cierta precariedad
aún en el sistema de justicia pero que
es salvado entre comillas por la
actuación individual de algunos fiscales
y esta relación vuelvo a subrayar está
en manos justamente de ese equipo que es
el que estaba liderando la lucha contra
la corrupción con ciertos resultados que
es el caso del equipo oficial ha bajado
alexandre cuál es su opinión en cuanto a
la independencia de poderes y la
autonomía que pueda tener la fiscalía
para llevar a cabo esta investigación
que como ustedes decían parte de unas
denuncias de la empresaria karelin lópez
no bueno yo creo que hemos avanzado
mucho en la independencia de los poderes
en los últimos 20 años yo he vivido mi
juventud digamos durante la década de
los 90s en donde definitivamente no
había independencia de poderes creo que
hemos avanzado mucho en ese plazo
en este trabajo pero en lo que toca
ahora es
cómo es que la prensa va a ir tocando
este tema no hay una especie de sinergia
fundamental entre lo que viene haciendo
la prensa a través de los destapes y lo
que viene haciendo la comisión especial
de la baja
la comisión digamos que está
investigando todos los temas de
corrupción no ahí es importante
mencionar por ejemplo que todos los
actos de corrupción que se han destapado
hoy y que están en juicios y en donde se
está investigando a expresidentes han
sido justamente gracias a los destapes
que ha hecho la prensa no entonces por
eso la figura de la colaboración eficaz
a la que se está sometiendo karelin
lópez es una figura que a mi juicio
puede generar
muchos aportes interesantes y sin
embargo hoy estamos en un contexto en el
que se han querido bajar esta figura
eliminar esta figura si quiero que con
los dos con alexandra y con luciano
hagamos el análisis de cómo afecta esto
la estabilidad y la imagen de perú por
fuera de las fronteras peruanas la
estabilidad política vemos ya muchos
años de crisis política en este país
múltiples gobiernos presidentes que
suben y bajan inconformismo por parte de
la ciudadanía elecciones y un parlamento
que simplemente pues sube y baja
presidentes dependiendo de las
circunstancias que se estén presentando
para cerrar este tema de la vacancia del
presidente antes de entrar a hablar de
la moción de confianza del gabinete de
ministros comienzo entonces con luciano
para darle la palabra cómo afecta esto a
la estabilidad otro capítulo más de
crisis pero parece que no logra
encontrar un punto de equilibrio en su
política
la razón por la que no se encuentra un
punto de equilibrio desde mi punto de
vista tiene que ver con la negativa de
las fuerzas políticas representadas en
el parlamento de sentar las bases de una
reforma política auténtica no y cuando
lo planteo en esos términos o porque en
realidad la crisis es la crisis de la
representación
el problema de no tener
unos partidos políticos sólidos que
lleven buenos cuadros que la política
sea atractiva para ciertos para
determinados ciudadanos es lo que nos
mete en esta crisis constante que está
mucho más agudizada desde el año 2016 en
que el señor putin se llevó al poder y
el fujimorismo tuvo una mayoría
aplastante que no la tenía del año 95
entonces me parece que hasta que nos
sentemos unas bases sólidas como para
tratar de generar unos partidos
políticos con adecuada representación
popular esto va a ser más que antes yo
termino con esta cuestión hablábamos
hace un momento de que la percepción de
la ciudadanía es que se vayan todos pero
varios décimos pero qué es lo que viene
lo que viene es mejor si igual o va a
ser peor el vaticinio es que vienen los
de siempre porque el problema de fondo
es que no hemos llegado a hacer la
reforma política el país necesita una
mejor y adecuada representación claro
alexandra su opinión y les doy paso a
otra pregunta
si en la misma línea justo ayer publiqué
una columna sobre el tema en donde decía
que como en el fútbol uno cambiando los
jugadores no vas a cambiar
necesariamente las reglas del juego no
entonces hay que apuntar a cambiar estas
reglas del juego que tenemos hoy y
fortalecer los sistemas de partidos los
is el sistema electoral sin embargo el
problema es quien decide hacer esta
reforma cuando los tomadores de decisión
o quienes están hoy en estos puestos
clave para tomar estas decisiones han
sido de alguna manera estos puestos
copados por mafias a favor de la
informalidad a favor de que esto
persista entonces no hay incentivos para
que la clase política que tenemos hoy
pueda apostar por una reforma política
sin embargo no soy tan pesimista creo
que la sociedad civil y la ciudadanía en
general sabe exigir y sabe que tiene el
poder de exigir determinados
determinadas cosas y creo que debería
pues ahora empezar a levantarse y pedir
no solamente la reforma política sino
también otras dos reformas que son
claves y que han quedado
invisibilizadas en estos años y que
ayudan también a
que las crisis políticas cullen en las
políticas públicas que es la reforma del
servicio civil para tener un cuerpo
sólido de servidores públicos que
implementen las políticas públicas
adecuadamente y aparatos administrativos
aparatos públicos eficientes efectivos
digamos con orientados a realmente
entregar calidad de vida a los
ciudadanos alexandra y es factible que
se vaya este congreso y lleguen nuevos
parlamentarios independientes que puedan
reformar leyes es posible que esto pase
a la luz de la constitución peruana que
también se vaya al presidente con esta
moción y se pueda ir el parlamento
también para dar una renovación esto
como como lo dice la ley
el presidente
vizcarra quien reemplazó a pedro pablo
kuczynski que fue elegido en el período
anterior pidió trabajar una reforma
política le pidió al congreso que
movilizará las aprobaciones para la
reforma política y se terminó cerrando
el congreso mucha gente salió a las
calles a celebrar este cierre del
congreso particularmente yo no celebré
que se cierre un poder pero mucha gente
estuvo contenta y esperanzada además en
que íbamos a tener un congreso mejor y
esto no ha sido así entonces la salida
hoy de estos jugadores como digo estos
actores de la escena no va
necesariamente a cambiar las cosas
porque lo que tenemos son las reglas del
juego
y equivocadas y que generan incentivos
perversos no claro otro punto destacado
de la agenda del día el jefe del
gabinete ministerial aníbal torres
presentaba hoy en el congreso todo su
gabinete para obtener el respaldo
necesario el voto de confianza necesario
del parlamento también noticia destacada
hoy ha hecho importante para la
estabilidad y para el gabinete del
gobierno del presidente castillo luciano
y también para está para esta votación
como están las cargas
y sé que hay varios ministros allí
señalados criticados y cuestionados que
tanto podría recibir rápidamente esta
aprobación como lo ve usted
me da la impresión que va a ser una
votación muy ajustada pero tengo la
impresión que le van a terminar dando la
confianza y eso un gabinete que está
pasando justamente por la crisis que
acabamos de comentar de los destapes de
karim lópez de la impopularidad de
cuadros que no están preparados para
hacer para ocupar cargos ministeriales
la confianza no está en el caso más
álgido es el del ministro de salud una
persona que no está preparada
definitivamente para el cargo lo lógico
y sensato sería no darle la confianza
pero el parlamento no se va a querer
quitar una vida porque la constitución
del perú establece que si existen dos
negaciones de confianza de parte del
parlamento al poder ejecutivo el
presidente está facultado a disolverlo
así que yo dudo mucho que este
parlamento
más bien vaya a hacer que las cosas la
votación sea muy ajustada pero que al
final le va a darle el voto de confianza
e intentar censurar a ministros uno por
uno la prueba de lo que digo es que está
convocado para el día 10 de marzo la
censura del ministro de salud y hoy
estamos discutiendo debatiendo en el
parlamento la confianza del gabinete por
la presentación de sus políticas de
gobierno por eso me atrevo a decir que
va a pasar como se dice a raspando pero
le van a dar la confianza porque el
parlamento no se va a querer suicidar
alexandra y en este escenario si el
parlamento no le da la confianza este
gabinete qué puede pasar ahora otra
crisis que se abre otro capítulo otra
puerta qué pasa ahí
sí bueno yo coincido con luciano creo
que es muy paradójico lo que ha dicho
pero sí es nuestra política bastante
paradójica por un lado se está juntando
las firmas para la vacancia y por otro
lado pedro castillo tiene la aritmética
a su favor para que pueda pasar como
dice raspando como se dice en perú y
obtener la confianza si es que no se le
da la confianza evidentemente vamos a
tener nuevamente una crisis de gabinete
pero no creo que esto sea una señal o
una motivación suficiente para que pueda
eros castillo pueda elegir un mejor
gabinete ya hemos visto que no está
necesariamente
concentrado o con las ganas necesarias
para mejorar la calidad de su gabinete y
si no todo lo contrario entonces yo
estoy desesperanzada un poquito frente a
lo que podríamos encontrar si es que se
niega la confianza no creo sinceramente
que se pueda tener un mejor gabinete
luciano cuántos votos se necesitan como
son estas estas votaciones para la
para darle la confianza al gabinete de
ministros
no se exige una mayoría calificada así
que es básicamente una mayoría simple no
no no se necesita la constitución del
perú ni tampoco el reglamento del
congreso que es el marco legal en el que
se desenvuelve el debate de hoy no hace
porque se necesitan dos tercios como por
ejemplo para un caso de la vacancia si
no es una mayoría legal del número de
congresistas así que por esas razones
también la impresión que me da es que va
a pasar el examen con una nota
aprobatoria de las más bajas que hay
pero va a pasar o sea no creo que ocurra
lo contrario por lo que veo el
parlamento va decidido a tratar de
censurar ministro por ministro hasta que
se genere esta situación indudablemente
paradójica alexandra de ir a una
vacancia presidencial confiando en los
destapes que puedan ser en los próximos
días para tratar de llegar a esa valla
alta de los 87 votos pero de qué va a
pasar va a pasar eso es lo que haremos
alexandra de luciano creo que les va a
hacer la pregunta más importante
de este debate como decimos la pregunta
del millón de dólares porque al
presidente castillo alexandra le ha
costado tanto
gobernar rodearse bien llevar a cabo sus
políticas pasar de las palabras a la
práctica la implementación y conformar
un gabinete que supuestamente es algo
que viene organizado y armado en un
andamiaje desde los momentos de la
campaña cuando el candidato ya asume el
cargo como presidente pues ya viene
rodeado de su equipo de trabajo para
empezar a trabajar y castillo siempre
está como en un constante reinicio de su
propio gobierno cada cierto tiempo y no
ha podido digamos en palabras más
simples despegar
mira efectivamente esa pregunta el
millón de dólares yo quisiera entender
un poco más por qué pedro castillo no
está orientado realmente en armar un
equipo capacitado comprometido con el
país y comprometido con estas promesas
desde la narrativa política que él
comentaba no nomás pobres en un país
rico y cumplir con la esperanza de la
gente que votó por él que fueron los más
vulnerables precisamente del país yo
creo que lo que prima hoy y lo que ha
primado particularmente sobre él es el
clientelismo
finalmente ha tenido una práctica en su
partido político o una práctica muy
propio que en las regiones o los
gobiernos regionales del perú en donde
se suele hacer ciertas promesas se
trabaja con una red de confianza muy
hermética y muy cerrada y luego cuando
se llega al poder es este grupo el que
toma todas las decisiones y no permite
que realmente personas que están
capacitadas que entienden de gestión
pública que entienden de políticas
públicas se involucren en el gobierno y
luciano su opinión
para mí por qué razones la primera
porque por improvisación usted este era
un candidato que fue a un partido como
un vientre de alquiler y ni siquiera es
militante de ese partido perú libre
así que definitivamente la primer la
primera característica improvisación la
segunda coincido con alexandra un
problema del cliente lage que desalienta
profesionales de buen nivel
quisieran ser parte de su gobierno y la
tercera razón que me parece que es la
más preocupante y que probablemente
podría ser la que lo lleve a ser
defenestrado por el parlamento son los
visos de corrupción en su gobierno que
creo que ya en los últimos tiempos han
sido cada vez más evidentes y que creo
que esas son las tres poderosas razones
por las que no pueden aún art se declaró
un moderno o sólido no me queda un
minuto para terminar el programa la
conclusión que va a suceder en perú
que viene para los próximos meses no
tenemos bola de cristal siempre lo digo
no sabremos el futuro pero desde su
perspectiva analysis alexandra que puede
suceder en su país rápidamente por favor
bueno vamos a seguir teniendo
estas crisis que tenemos con la hoja
bien es el gran gabinetes creo que para
pedro castillo es normal cambiar de
gabinete no no es algo que le quita el
sueño y por lo tanto pues los ciudadanos
vamos a estar viviendo estos pedidos de
confianza por unas unos meses más y
luciano su conclusión para el cierre
para mí una agudización de la crisis
política en una lucha por el poder entre
las fuerzas que están en el parlamento y
el ejecutivo el desenlace que va a
aparecer entiendo yo y que va a terminar
para mí defenestrando casi yo no veo que
castillo avance en su gobierno lo que
veo el que va a ser defenestrado y muy
probado por los destapes de corrupción y
muy probablemente esta lucha entre ambos
poderes el estado sea en captar el
ejecutivo en la sucesión presidencial un
desenlace bastante agudo es el género de
prisión y política que nos espera aquí
en el perú lamentablemente
alexandra de luciano en la ciudad de
lima la capital de perú muchas gracias
por este análisis para la audiencia de
france 24 en américa latina' ustedes
pueden seguir dejando sus comentarios y
todas sus preguntas a través de las
redes sociales de la cadena sigan en
sintonía de france 24
[Música]